we created this this and this in just a
minute are you excited to learn about a
free AI generator that can create all
these interesting Graphics by feeding
the correct prompt and do you know it's
so easy to use generating air can be a
fascinating and rewarding experience for
beginners interested in exploring the
intersection of Art and Technology
before we begin if these are the videos
you like to watch then don't forget to
hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon to get notified every time we
upload a new video this tutorial will go
through the basics of generating air
including the tools and techniques
needed to create stunning visual designs
whether an artist or a developer this
guide will help you generate air and
inspire you to create your unique
Masterpiece within a few minutes so
let's dive in and explore the world of
air okay so the easiest way to access
this is join the Discord first if you
don't have Discord then you can easily
download it from discord.com if you are
not familiar with Discord it's actually
like a WhatsApp for community is then go
to midjourney.com select join the beta
or you can go directly to the
mid-journey discard after that you have
to find a newbies Channel select any
newbies channel on the military official
server that is visible in the left
sidebar after joining the newbies
Channel you can explore various Discord
commands to create images change default
settings and perform other helpful tasks
the slash imagine command generate a
unique image from a short text
description known as a prom wanna know
how type slash imagine prompt or select
the slash imagine command from the slash
command pop-up type a description of the
image you want to create in the prompt
field dark playing ball in space or Iron
Man merged with the Batman or landscape
transition from Winter to Spring click
the enter key to send your message so
the next is processing the job the mid
Journey board will generate four
variations in a minute the free midterm
neutral is activated when an image is
generated any action using the mid
Journey bot is known as a job and jobs
like scaling images creating image
variations or creating a grid of images
using the slash imagine command all uses
your trial periods to find out how much
time is left in your trial use it slash
info command to check your first time
remaining after that we have upscale
variations now two rows of buttons
appear after the initial image grid has
finished generated here U stands for
upscale which means if I like one of
these it scale it up to full resolution
or create a larger version of The Chosen
image and add more details and v stands
for I like this version a new image grid
created as a variation is modeled after
the general and composition of the
selected image so I'm thinking version 3
is writer and is closest to my vision so
I will just say V3 so I'll go ahead and
say upskill too and there you have it
you can bring your unique and quirky
imaginations into exciting visuals like
this apart from this you can go for
subscribed version of mid Journey with
10 dollars per month 30 dollars per
month and a new 60 dollars per month
plan or you can just stick to the free
trial with 25 Generations which you can
use immediately upon joining the Discord
in conclusion you learn about the
mid-journey subscription and its feature
in this tutorial if you want some cool
pictures to show off using an image
generator is a great choice however
other options like Euro flash are easier
to use and provide the best result in
the matter of seconds do you have any
doubt about mid-journey please let us
know your queries in the comment box
below and we will be back to you as soon
as possible stay tuned to Simply learn
and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here